il doit éviter les dérives idéologiques
merci de le souligner comment peut-on
reconstituer une sixième république qui
ne soit pas l'oublié parlementaire ça se
passe en direct puisque on est en direct
il ya quand même la liberté vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce jeudi 10 février
changement de cap emmanuel macron sur sa
stratégie énergétique
le président confirme la construction de
6 nouveaux réacteurs en france annonce
depuis belfort du chef de l'état qui
pourtant en 2017 avait promis de réduire
le nucléaire à 50% de la production
électrique huit paires supplémentaires
sont à l'étude également un programme
nucléaire très critiqué notamment par
les écologistes pour yannick jadot
emmanuel macron condamne la france à un
siècle de nucléaire nucléaire en france
quoi qu'il en coûte on attend vos
réactions sur le conte télégramme verte
et france
tout comme la stratégie énergétique la
question du pouvoir d'achat est au
centre des thèmes favoris de la campagne
présidentielle les candidats et vendent
leurs propositions souvent axées sur la
hausse des salaires
objectif répondre à l'inquiétude des
français qui voient leur facture grimper
alors quelle grande tendance à fond dans
cette campagne qui comprend le mieux les
attend des ménages sur le pouvoir
d'achat on en parle tout à l'heure avec
jacques sapir dans son édito échos
et puis au sommaire à 21h la crise je
craignais navech la poursuite du ballet
diplomatique aujourd'hui c'est la
ministre britannique des affaires
étrangères qui s'est entretenu avec son
homologue russe à moscou le premier
ministre britannique est lui à bruxelles
pour rencontrer le patron de l'otan
des discussions qui continuent alors que
les populations s'inquiètent pour la
suite on retrouvera notre envoyé spécial
depuis le dombass ira à la rencontre
ceux qui vivent depuis des années au
rythme de la guerre
le traitement des rdt est justement sur
le dossier ukrainien pointé du doigt par
certains de nos confrères d'où ce papier
publié sur la défense en pas moins d'une
semaine dont un dans lequel on apprend
qu'une enquête de l'art comme le nouveau
nom du csa est lancée à l'origine de
cette saisine une jeune association
médias démocratie euro créé il y à peine
quelques mois vous en parlerons avec nos
invités à 21h15 dans notre deuxième
partie d'émission
[Musique]
emmanuel macron à belfort donc cet après
midi pour parler nucléaire le chef de
l'état a dévoilé un vaste plan de
relance du secteur un discours aux
allures de campagne présidentielle
les détails avec thibaut janin
s'est depuis le site de fabrication des
turbines arabelle à belfort qui emmanuel
macron a dévoilé sa stratégie
énergétique pour la france de 2030 pour
arriver à une décarbonation total le
chef de l'état me sur une alliance entre
nucléaire et énergies renouvelables pour
produire cette électricité de manière la
plus décarbonés
la plus sûre
la plus souveraine
est justement d'avoir une stratégie
pluriel celle que nous avons choisis sur
la base de ces travaux est de développer
tout à la fois les énergies
renouvelables et le nucléaire c'est que
nous n'avons d'autre choix que de miser
en même temps sur ces deux piliers une
combinaison qui serait donc la plus
pertinente selon le chef de l'état
concernant le secteur renouvelables il a
annoncé l'implantation de 50 parc éolien
en mer d'ici 2050 mais surtout emmanuel
macron a détaillé un vaste plan de
relance du nucléaire en france parmi les
annonces marquantes la prolongation de
tous les réacteurs qui peuvent l'être au
delà de 50 ans et la construction d'une
série de nouveaux compte tenu des
besoins en électricité
de la nécessité d'anticiper
aussi la transition la fin du parc
existant qui ne pourra être prolongé
indéfiniment
nous allons lancer dès aujourd'hui un
programme de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires
je souhaite que six paires 2 soit
construit et que nous lancions les
études sur la construction de huit le
pr2 additionnel avec une mise en service
du premier ep r2 vers 2035 complété par
de petits réacteurs modulable et des
réacteurs innovant produisant moins de
déchets une renaissance du nucléaire
français selon emmanuel macron qui
coïncide avec le rachat par edf d'une
partie de l'activité nucléaire de
general electric dont les turbines
arabes elles qui avaient été vendus en
2015 au géant américain lorsque le
locataire de l'elysée était encore
ministre de l'économie du côté de
l'opposition les réactions ne se sont
pas fait attendre pour condamner le
discours du chef de l'état une nouvelle
fois un homme tout seul décide d'engager
le pays dans le tout nucléaire pour les
30 prochaines années et d'allonger
lusage des vieilles centrales pour 30
ans de plus ni expertise ni étude
d'impact ni plan le fait du prince ça y
est emmanuel macron s'est exprimé sur la
relance du nucléaire et le résultat est
encore pire que ce que nous anticipions
nous appelons à la mobilisation générale
macron annonce une relance du nucléaire
après avoir annoncé en 2018 la fermeture
de 14 réacteurs le en même temps
énergétique est mortel pour notre
indépendance le candidat macron et il
informait du bilan du président macron
qui a démantelé le nucléaire et fermer
fessenheim des critiques sur un sujet
clivant de la campagne présidentielle
pour laquelle emmanuel macron n'a
toujours pas annoncé sa candidature
alors convaincus ou pas par ce programme
de construction de nouveaux réacteurs
pourquoi le président fait un virage à
360 degrés après avoir défendu la
réduction de la part du nucléaire
nucléaire en france quoi qu'il en coûte
on attend vos réactions sur le conte
télégramme d'ayrté france et place un
autre débat
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler sur ce plateau
anthony gratacos secrétaire général de
la gauche républicaine et socialistes
bonsoir avec nous également en plateau
alex entouré vice-président l ère du
département de l'essonne et puis en
duplex un claude brender merde
fessenheim sans étiquette ainsi que
christophe grudler député européen modem
bonsoir à tous les deux merci de nous
accompagner clos de brenner première
question pour vous quand vous entendez
ce virage à 360 degrés
emmanuel macron qui veut prolonger tous
les réacteurs je cite un qui peuvent
l'être au delà de 50 ans si possible
évitez d'en fermer votre centrale on le
sait a était elle fermée comment vous
réagissez ce soir
mais côté c'est mitigé partagé entre
finalement une bonne une bande annonce
pour le pour le pays pour la filière
nucléaire et puis par contre une prise
de conscience un peu tardive pour notre
notre centrale celle de fessenheim qui a
été arrêté par le par ce même président
et qui deux ans après relance de deux
nouveaux réacteurs et donc c'est il est
vrai que j'attendais une annonce pour
fessenheim pour dire ok j'ai bien pris
le message que fessenheim a été
sacrifiée
finalement aimé mais voilà cette annonce
est pas arrivé je ne désespère pas que
ses semelles puisse avoir un nouvel et
soan une nouvelle une nouvelle
perspective de production nucléaire en
france et sur le site de la centrale
christophe grébert vous sautez la
majorité c'est vrai que quand on entend
ce maire qui voit là et quand même
magnanime il n'attaque pas trop emmanuel
macron mais enfin il le dit quand même
fessenheim a été d'une certaine manière
sacrifiés et si on suit la logique du
président de la république elles
n'auraient pas dû l'être
quelle réaction aujourd'hui ce vol fasse
par toutes les personnes peut-être
qu'ils ont perdu leur emploi à
fessenheim bas côté pour moi il n'y a
pas de volte-face il y avait une
décision du président hollande dans le
cadre d'une entente avec les verts qui
sont farouchement opposés au nucléaire
donc avant avant 2010 est donc et le
président rollandin programmé la
fermeture de fessenheim qui allait
jusqu'au bout des des processus
évidemment moi je soutiens la filière
nucléaire sous toutes ses formes ce soit
la forme de v r2 de est sévère il ya
toute une gamme en fait de deux produits
nucléaires qui sont très utiles à la
décarbonation de l'union européenne et
je pense que fessenheim a toute sa place
dans la future écriture on va dire de
les scénarios énergétiques qu'on peut
avoir en france notamment avec toujours
un petit problème pour fessenheim sait
que c'est sur le rhin et qu'en face il
ya les allemands qui sont profondément
anti nucléaire et qui vont faire encore
une plus grande pression sur la france
pour qu'on ne met rien à fessenheim
voilà ça fait partie de la géopolitique
c'est un peu ce que j'ai remis au
parlement européen les relations avec
les voisins et c'est de voir comment on
peut trouver quelque chose de consensuel
mais moi je pense que pour fessenheim
très clairement les smr peuvent être une
solution une semaine on va on va mettre
en place
centrale de small modular hector donc
les petit réacteur modulaire c'est
certes plus petit mais c'est un produit
d'avenir à autour de 340 mégawatts et
qui peut avoir un intérêt d'être posée
sur un site comme celui fait cela
anthony gratacos on l'entend oui on se
souvient emmanuel macron qui se targue
d'avoir finalement tenu la promesse de
françois hollande vous étiez à l'époque
au parti socialiste certes un petit peu
frondeur on s'en souvient
mais moi il aurait finalement pas dû
tenir cette promesse de peur de se
déjuger aujourd'hui elle était encore
réversible quand emmanuel macron est
devenu président de la république je
crois que maintenant c'est trop tard
dont le processus de démantèlement de la
centrale je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
revenir en arrière mais c'est au delà de
la question de fessenheim de toute façon
au président de la république même si on
peut être en accord avec les annonces
qui ont été faites aujourd'hui et qui
sont courageuses par rapport au contexte
européen à la pression que les allemands
mettent au niveau européen ils viennent
de contester par exemple la taxonomie
européenne qui explique clairement que
le nucléaire est une énergie verte ce
que nous nous pensons donc c'est assez
courageux mais il remet absolument pas
en cause tout le système qui nous a
menés avant d'être là aujourd'hui sur la
privatisation du marché et la
dérégularisation du marché de l'énergie
et sur la destruction d'edf et de gdf
qui nous mène aujourd'hui à un problème
de souveraineté en terme en matière
d'énergie alors que c'est au fond le
débat est le sujet le plus important de
ce siècle à la fois pour répondre à la
question du développement durable et de
la protection de l'environnement mais
aussi pour répondre aux questions de
souveraineté parce qu'on le voit avec
l'allemagne qui aujourd'hui prend des
décisions sur la question du gaz russe
qui dépend entièrement de ses intérêts
énergétiques et donc qui n'est plus
totalement souverain je ne veux pas que
la france on arrive à ce genre de
situation demain alors il dit emmanuel
macron effectivement il faut reprendre
le field de la grande aventure du
nucléaire civil un il y revenait
d'ailleurs un petit peu sur ses
adversaires qui affirme que nous
n'aurions pas besoin du nucléaire
alexandre touzet que vous ont évoqué ces
grandes envolées lyriques
alors qu'il disait quand même un petit
peu son contraire effectivement en 2002
17 c'est un constat d'échec un constat
d'échec que les diffi cilement nos
habitants des territoires européens
robin et que l'énergie qui augmente un
constat d'échec sur nos paysages parce
que ça a quand même été sa cage france
avec ses éoliennes un constat d'échec en
termes d'indépendance et vous l'avez dit
puisque aujourd'hui dans le cadre des
conflits mondiaux on voit bien que les
états unis sont obligés d'intervenir
pour nous pour que les pays de l'opep
nous délivre un peu plus d'énergie c'est
un sac à chaud enfin un constat d'échec
sur tous les plans et aujourd'hui on a
un effet girouette parce qu'il a été
bien il n'a pas été synchro pouvoir
était dix ans au pouvoir il était
secrétaire général de l'elysée elle
était ministre de l'économie il a été
président de la république et au dernier
moment tout d'un coup on a un volte face
alors que dans la loi aujourd'hui
toujours dans la loi on a pris est
inscrit la limitation à 50 % dans le mix
énergétique du nucléaire il est inscrit
dans la loi la fermeture de centrales
nucléaires tout ça n'a pas changé en
cinq ans donc écouter c'est plus un
président de la république c'est une
girouette face je pense qu'on a un vrai
problème de crédibilité du pays en ce
moment on va justement écouter ce que
vous venez nous décrire un c'était
emmanuel macron le 9 février 2017
nous réduirons notre dépendance à
l'énergie nucléaire avec l'objectif de
50% d'énergie nucléaire à l'horizon 2025
ce n'est pas bon d'avoir 75 % de notre
énergie qui vient du nucléaire
clos de brenner clairement aujourd'hui
c'est un aveu d'impuissance ou comédie
avec 112 est un aveu d'échec ou tout
simplement on est en train de découvrir
en france qu'on ne peut pas se passer
pour différentes raisons qu'on dont on
va débattre ici mais qu'on ne peut tout
simplement pas se passer du nucléaire
même est clairement erronées là dans les
limites du en même temps c'est à dire un
moment donné et les vrai qu on attendait
nous du président d'un jeune président
et d'un président un peu pragmatique qui
revoit cette promesse de françois
hollande qui remettent ce le débat sur
sur fès m sur le nucléaire sur la table
en début de mandat et pas en fin de
mandat ensuite donc il aurait très bien
pu revenir sur cette décision
d'autant plus que fait m a été décoré
les de la fed de l'ouverture de
flamanville donc c'est donc c'était
quand même bien la volonté de tenir ses
promesses de françois hollande donc il
aurait pu s'en passer et donc
aujourd'hui finalement je chasse et
naturel il revient au galop je dire on
pourra pas faire sans nucléaire c'est
évident c'est une évidence et on voit
bien en allemagne qui qui qui à marche
forcée mettre des éoliennes partout et
finalement se retrouve à être dépendant
du gaz de la ligne du charbon et donc
les leurs leur production électrique
élèves et les 4 5 fois su aimer plus de
co2 que le mix poncet donc chercher
l'erreur ils ont mis 500 milliards sur
la table pour pour mettre des éoliennes
partout pour saccager leur paysage et de
leur pays
on veut pas ça en france je pense que
personne ne veut donc le nucléaire est
incontournable c'est comme ça à ma table
ont peut-être la fusion peut-être
d'autres d'eau d'énergie mais pour ce
siècle là il faut en cours de l'énergie
nucléaire c'est évident effectivement
christophe grudler pense aussi que là
c'est ce que nous dit aussi en substance
assez amer et yannick jadot ans qui a
exprimé sa colère avant même qu emmanuel
macron prennent la parole il dit on va
s'en prendre jusqu'à la fin du siècle c
c'est ainsi qu'on voit les choses et
comme on lit on n'a pas le choix ça veut
dire qu'on n'a pas eu la bonne vision et
les bonnes stratégies en amont
pour yannick geslot tu redonnes donc
dans le domaine futur éviter plus
dogmatique chez les écologistes art il y
en a quelques-uns merlus ont fait partie
il fallait dire clairement il ne veut
pas nucléaire donc à partir de ce
moment-là vous essayez de tous démontré
pour arriver à ce résultat c'est pas
très positif lorsque je veux simplement
dire c'est qu'il ya pas eu de volte-face
comme j'entends dire quand même par
monsieur 12 et salua rush peut-être la
bouche de dire aujourd'hui que ce qui
était annoncé et bien ça il pourrait
aussi avoir le courage politique de le
dire mais en 2018 le président de la
république a commandé des études
énergétiques soient les futurs
énergétique de la france c'était bien
pour savoir vers quoi on devait
s'orienter au niveau énergétique les
scénarios de de rte ont été rendu il ya
quelques mois seulement et disent
clairement que sans nucléaire il n'y a
pas de décarbonation possible de la
france est également d'ailleurs de
l'union européenne donc on a
effectivement besoin du nucléaire on
avait besoin d'un plan d'une vision et l
annonce de 6 p r tout de suite et 2,8
encore autres mis en chantier derrière
c'est sûr que c'est un chantier
monumental de plusieurs dizaines de
milliards mais qui sont indispensables
parce que notre production électrique
elle va doubler on va passer 25 % de
production d'électricité dans le mix
énergétique à 55% donc en fait aux
barbus loin de davantage de moyens de
production et le moyenne le seul moyen
de production pilotable décarbonée c'est
le nucléaire donc il faut évidemment pas
s'en priver est-ce que sinon
effectivement ce sont les moyens
polluants qui permettront de réguler
l'intermittence des énergies
renouvelables car effectivement le
nucléaire qui est déjà très puissant qui
représente une grosse grosse part dans
notre pays regardez la france deuxième
pays le plus nucléarisé au monde quand
même après les les états unis 1 70% de
la production d'électricité
tricolore provient de la tome 4 régions
qui assure plus de 80% de la production
nucléaire alexandre tous et ça ça vous
évoque quoi le deuxième pays le plus
puissant en terme le nucléaire après les
états unis il a écouté une grande fierté
moi je suis très heureux quand la france
peut être autonome quand la france est
souveraine quand il ya des savoir faire
industriels et je crois qu'il ya un des
enjeux qui est devant nous c'est la
reconquête de ses savoir faire
industriel ce que j'aurai dire c'est que
en fait sur l'énergie et pour répondre
on charcute des députés européens on a
la même chose qu'elle sur sur la
sécurité au fond saut à la fin du mandat
qu'on découvre qu'il ya des problèmes et
là tout d'un coup on s'agite on fait des
commissions fait des études gouverner
c'est pas ça qui un temps de réflexion
tout le monde ici peut l'admettre
effectivement n'a pas quand on est
candidat forcément tout une vision on
prend connaissance même s'il était
secrétaire général adjoint de l'elysée
même si les mises l'économie je pense
que il avait quand même un centre de
données mais on décide pas de l'avenir
énergétique de la france à quelques
semaines de la campagne présidentielle
l'arrière pensée c'est quoi il était en
campagne emmanuel macron ou peut-être
tape ukrainienne il se rend compte que
plus que jamais il faut être indépendant
c'est ça mais le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui ont du
der est à vivre dans les milieux ruraux
au père riba parce qu'ils sont obligés
de prendre leur voiture moi j'habite
dans un territoire urbain il ya un train
qui passe de temps en temps je peux vous
dire qu'aujourd'hui la politique des
manuels macro on la voit qu'en france sa
voiture on la voit quand on se chauffe
et moi je veux bien qu'on me dise qu'il
a fallu cinq ans pour étudier le sujet
il ya un petit problème monsieur le
député européen moi je veux bien que
vous ne plus me disais ça moi je gère
une commune je suis vice-président un
département je vais pas cinq ans
étudiant un problème sinon les gens me
vire je veux dire il ya un moment non
mais parlez moi mais je pense que
l'action politique doit avoir un lien
avec l'efficacité sinon n'est plus
crédible et je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a
vraiment un problème de crédibilité et
je le dis et je suis d'accord avec vous
les 6e perth on le retrouve dans le
programme de valérie pécresse donc je ne
veux pas dire je suis content on le
retrouve mais simplement si vous avez
lancé ça il ya cinq ans eh bien on se
serait retrouvés et je voudrais
féliciter mais aujourd'hui et c'est très
malheureux parce que j'aurais aimé vous
féliciter mais je peux pas le faire
parce que le prix à la pompe élevé
puisque le reste à vivre pour les gens
aujourd'hui eh ben ils voient que ça
diminue les filets travaux d'efficacité
énergétique sur les bâtiments publics
chez les particuliers ça pas avancer les
transports publics sa pas suffisamment
avancé les énergies propres alternatifs
parce que y'en à la biomasse le bois etc
on n'a pas suffisamment avancé donc je
suis désolé j'aurais aimé le faire je
suis pas dans une démarche politique
mais franchement établir un diagnostic
énergétique de la france quelques
semaines avant l'élection présidentielle
j'aurais du mal oui à vous féliciter
parce que je serais même pas crédible
vis-à-vis de mes concitoyens la réponse
si vous permettez c'est pas le président
qui décide et sa maintenance irt eux
donc le transporteur public
d'électricité français a mis autant de
temps parce qu'il faut il faut quand
même une expertise très poussée il a
fait cette expertise très poussées il la
remet il y a deux mois au président de
la république c'est public donc tout le
monde voit les différents scénarios il
ya des choix à prendre et un président
de la république responsable qui
gouverne et bien il prend ses décisions
maintenant il se dit pas et la campagne
électorale on va faire un musée on va
présenter des jolies choses on va se
battre complètement à me pécresse je ne
sais qui non j'ai des traces des ligues
et céline là il faut absolument agir au
nom de l'intérêt national qui est notre
souveraineté énergétique il faut
vraiment qu'on puisse avoir cette
capacité à dire ensemble ok on part là
dessus et après on parle de différences
dans le cadre de la campagne qui va
arriver pour tout le monde très bientôt
mais je pense qu'il faut pas mélanger
les choses s'il avait s'ils n'avaient
pas agi vous auriez dit encore dans un
mois il a pour arriver assez vite que ce
qu'il fait il sait rien là dessus là il
agi suite à un rapport qui vient lui est
rendu et ah bah non il va trop vite mais
bon donc voilà dix fois un petit peu
être cohérent sur la lutte contre
l'augmentation des prix je rappelle
comme tous les efforts qui ont été faits
par bercy par notamment bruno le maire
le gouvernement est donc le présenter
république pour limiter la hausse des
prix pour les pour les concitoyens et
comme on est dans des campagnes
électorales c'est vrai que l'effort
était supportée par edf voilà on accuse
président de la république d'avoir fait
reporter sa part edf s'il n'avait pas
fait porté par edf on se serait plaint
que les prix auraient augmenté pour les
gens donc si un moment faut être
cohérent là je pense que ça va vraiment
dans le bon sens et faut lire moi je
suis la majorité présidentielle s'il
n'allait pas dans le bon sens je vous le
dirai avec autant de franchise parce que
j'ai oublié le dogme au parlement
européen ont travaillé un peu avec tous
les groupes politiques est ce que vous
dites ce que vous dites pardon sur la
biomasse sur les autres énergies c'est
le green deal européen qui est en train
d'être terminée au niveau de jeu
législatif au mieux au niveau du
parlement européen dans quatre mois on
saura tout les financements qu'on aura
notamment pour l'efficacité énergétique
pour l'isolation des bâtiments pour la
biomasse pour l'intégration l'hydrogène
dans les transports etc donc il ya un
travail qui se fait avec des faces un
peu j'espère
donner distribuer la parole
équitablement à propos de financement
est évident c'est une question qui se
pose c'est un programme nucléaire d'une
ampleur inégalée depuis 40 ans montant
de ce programme est estimé entre 50 et
60 milliards d'euros sur près de 30 ans
anthony gratacos
inquiétez-vous sur justement le
financement de ce programme assez
ambitieux oui bien sûr on est inquiet
parce que le président fait des annonces
qui vont plutôt dans le bon sens mais
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas avec quel
moyen le détricotage d'edf gdf avec sa
privatisation aujourd'hui fait qu edf
est dans une situation extrêmement
délicate qu'ils allaient qu'elle a perdu
beaucoup en puissance et l'état lui fait
effectivement payé la libéralisation du
marché par exemple en décidant qu'elle
va vendre moins cher l'électricité à ses
concurrents qui va la vendre on sait pas
pourquoi il existe ces gens là à part
pour faire monter les prix au final tout
le monde se fait avoir à la fois la
société mère car investi pendant des
décennies pour développer les réseaux
les centrales et c'est le consommateur
qui voit les prix augmenter et l'état
qui n'a plus l'exercice de sa
souveraineté via une politique
énergétique efficace et ça il ne le
remet absolument pas en cause après le
débat sur le financement il va venir
avec le temps puisque ça va ça va se
faire petit à petit mais il suffit de
prendre un exemple très simple france
2030 qui a été présenté récemment sur
les questions de réindustrialisation sur
lequel il ya des enjeux de développement
durable et énergétique c'est 4 milliards
d'euros pour la loi de prod2
la loi de programmation financière de
l'année prochaine 4 milliards d'euros
c'est même pas ce qu'a coûté la
suppression de l' isf sur le dernier
mandat d' emmanuel macron donc
sait rien on ne met pas les moyens
nécessaires et si on veut retrouver une
politique énergétique forte il faut
absolument commencer par renationaliser
edf et sortir du marché dérégulé de
l'énergie pour qu'on puisse que l'état
et les moyens de la puissance de l'état
pour pouvoir agir à la fois sur les prix
et sur les investissements aujourd'hui
c'est très compliqué en tout cas à
gauche à on prône la sortie du nucléaire
je vous propose justement de de jallet
j'allais y venir justement dans le
détail je les avais y venir je vous
prend vous propose de regarder les
propositions des candidats à la
présidentielle à marine le pen un qui
veut rouvrir ça va vous faire plaisir
rwandair rouvrir l'ancienne centrale
nucléaire de fessenheim retirer toutes
les éoliennes à elle va pas être
contente marine le pen parce qu'il ya eu
les noms sont à en parler aussi si on a
le temps de brader des éoliennes
également aujourd'hui valérie pécresse
et l'ère eric zemmour construire des
nouveaux ep est ré puis à gauche anne
hidalgo au ps jean luc mélenchon et
yannick jadot la france insoumise sortir
du nucléaire avec évidemment les jets
les écologistes christiane taubira quand
elle veut remettre en place un
référendum il ya que finalement fabien
roussel pcf qui veut maintenir le
nucléaire
ce sont vous êtes plutôt satisfait du
coup aujourd'hui toujours sur la même
ligne valérie pécresse et emmanuel
macron se rejoint en tout cas sur cette
question de du nucléaire alors il ya
d'autres propositions dans le programme
la grèce notamment sur le prix les
discussions au niveau européen comment
on arrive à avoir des contrats pour les
grandes entreprises consommatrices
d'énergie pour élever la compétitivité
du pays
yar sur les éoliennes grande différence
on le dit très concrètement et j'aurais
parce que là aussi on tape les ruraux
les périodes 1 il n'ya pas d'éoliennes
dans le 7e arrondissement
et ce sont des personnes qui acquièrent
un logement ils ont beaucoup de mal à le
vendre dans certaines zones parce que
dans le rural un petit peu reculer part
c'est plus difficile de vendre son
logement c'est leur seul bien et on est
en train de leur mettre une éolienne
contre l'avis de leur mère contre l'avis
de ces populations là est en train
d'évaluer leur bien la seule chose qui
possède la seule chose qu'ils peuvent
transmettre à leurs enfants et là on dit
bon c'est pas très grave c'est pas très
grave nous de paris on est les bobos
vent décide maintenant c'est pas comme
ça qu'on respecte les gens c'est pas
comme ça qu'on respecte les français et
moi je voudrais vraiment que sur les
éoliennes parce qu'on a eu les gilet
jaune il faut comprendre un moment que
ces français qui vivent dans leurs mains
dans l'eau devra l'on doit un minimum
est respecté il n'y a pas que les
métropoles quand je sais que la france
de mâcon sa france de métropole c'est la
france des gens qui peuvent vivre qui
vit bien qui ont trois stations de métro
quand ils descendent de chez eux il ya
des gens qui y vivent pas comme ça il ya
des gens qui ont mis toutes leurs
économies dans une maison ri quand leurs
plantes une éolienne en face à huy sont
pas contents et j'aurais qu'on arrête ce
la jarrie qu'on écoute les maires voilà
monsieur macron écoute les maires ça
serait très bien si vous pouvez lui
transmettre le message ce que j'ai cru
comprendre que vous étiez un vous étiez
francs monsieur le député européen donc
si vous pouvez lui transmettre d'écouter
les maires qu'on leur dit quelque chose
ça sera très bien parce qu'il les a
trouvés quand il y avait du gilet jaune
pour organiser les débats il faudra qui
les écoute quand il ya des problèmes des
éoliennes
oui je vais de vous donner la parole
mais je voudrais d'abord vous faire
écouter manuel macron sur justement
c'est tellement sur les éoliennes
l'éolien en mer sera développé pour
visée de l'ordre de 40 gigawatts en
service en 2050 soit une cinquantaine de
parcs éoliens en r
d cette année nous mettrons en activité
le premier parc éolien en mer
au large de saint nazaire
mais là aussi ce que nous avons commencé
de faire c'est de recréer déployer une
filière industrielle française
les usines du havre de saint nazaire de
cherbourg permettront de fournir tous
les équipements nécessaires et nous
allons continuer de développer là aussi
l'emploi industriel et les
investissements pour que ces choix fort
de l'éolien en mer soit accompagnée de
créations d'emplois partout sur notre
territoire
ces annonces sur ces fameuses éoliennes
offshore et puis ce message télégramme à
l'instant qui fait un peu sourire hélène
soto qui nous dit impossible de se
passer du nucléaire les énergies
renouvelables et alternatives sont
largement suffisantes face à nos besoins
à moins de pédaler pour faire tourner
son ego lienne dans le jardin claude
brender c'est vrai que cette question
des éoliennes elles suscitent parfois
les crispations emmanuel macron tout à
leur disait mais non ça n'empêche pas la
protection de l'environnement du paysage
votre avis sur le sujet
écoutez je pense que tu tout et
complémentaires aucune énergie n'est
arrêté mais bon pour pour autant il faut
rester raisonnable et aujourd'hui
l'éolien peut avoir de l'intérêt dans
d'autres certaines de dans certaines
régions pour venir compléter le
dispositif mais 100% renouvelable et
100% intermittence et c'est pas possible
donc on tout le monde le sait et donc
ensuite je pense que l'énergie c'est
vraiment un sujet sérieux alors tout le
monde un petit à
des intervenants qui sont qui sont
arrivés aujourd'hui en avant n'a faibli
effet edf on se sert d'edf pour pour la
politique énergétique et donc à des bus
électoraux dans ensuite il faudra
peut-être arrêter le ping pong des ddd
au changement majorité je change de
stratégie énergétique je pense que c'est
pas ça pense que le l'énergie est
sérieux et devrait devrait être inscrit
quasiment de ses pas dans la
constitution faire un référendum
pourquoi pas mais mais qu'on arrête de
faire du ping pong au gré des
changements de majorité et je pense que
les financements si on parle de
financement investir dans le nucléaire
c'est bien moins cher que d'investir
dans l'éolien et au shore et autres et
parce que bon derrière c'est beaucoup
plus 2 milliards qu'il faut qu'il va
falloir y mettre en panne et data cross
oui bien sûr mais alors effectivement le
monsieur le maire a raison il peut avoir
un intérêt installer des parcs
d'éoliennes offshore bon même si je suis
d'accord aussi sur le fait qu'il faut
écouter et je suis moi même élu local à
un moment il faut on peut pas utiliser
les maires les départements les régions
que quand on en a besoin quand on on
doit travailler avec lui on doit les
écouter on doit entendre ce qu'ils
disaient les populations avaient elles
n'ont pas été écoutés effectivement mais
surtout moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est que
au delà de ces annonces on a aujourd'hui
des outils qui existent en france pour
pouvoir développer l'énergie
différemment je pense par exemple à
l'hydroélectrique et aujourd'hui nos
serres que de régulateurs de production
il est largement sous utilisé
on ne fait plus d'investissements dans
ce domaine en plus il est menacé par une
volonté de l'union européenne de
privatiser donc de vendre ces barrages
qui est très dangereux parce qu'on parle
beaucoup d'accident nucléaire les trois
accident nucléaire majeur ont lieu dans
le monde deux étaient des entreprises
privées et après tchernobyl c'est un
sujet assez particulier mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que on a des moyens
avant de déclencher des milliards dans
des choses dont on ne sait pas bien
comment on va les retraités après parce
que ce ne sont pas des installations de
long terme
donc on parle des déchets nucléaires
c'est pas comme en retraite les
éoliennes une fois qu'elles ont arrêté
de produire les installations elles
existent peut-être faudrait-il en
développer d'autres sur
l'hydroélectrique et je serais curieux
de voir d'ailleurs la réaction de
certains écologistes qui vont nous
expliquer que tel vallée tel endroit
peut pas être utilisé pour faire de
l'hydroélectrique alors que c'est une
énergie propre et que quand on va les
privatiser on voit les mêmes sur les
barrages pour les défendre on me
l'aurait empêché de les faire il ya 50
ans donc on est dans un paradoxe assez
intéressant mais là ça ne demande pas
des investissements massifs sa demande
de changer de politique et
d'organisation dans la priorité du mix
énergétique français et j'invite le
président à le faire et je pose la
question je m'associe à mon collègue
pour poser la question aux députés
européens et lui dire et il expliqué
emmanuel macron que deux au lieu de
faire des annonces qui sont électorale
on mène une vraie politique énergétique
dans ce pays et qu'ils en discutent avec
les français christophe grudler vous
allez passer le message emmanuel macron
d'écouté très volontiers mais je pense
qu'il n'a pas besoin je pense qu'il a
une vraie vision pour la france il y
avait une vraie vraie vision pour les
français une vraie vision énergétique et
c'est vraiment ce qu'il apportait
aujourd'hui à belfort qui n'ait accès
sûrement pas une métropole donc tout ne
se passe pas en métropole c'est le
vice-président donc voilà ça y est j'y
suis aussi attaché à sa peut-être trop
petite remarque rapide sur les éoliennes
moi je crois plutôt à fond aux éoliennes
et sap sur la fin et en mer on peut se
retrouver sur l'hydroélectrique le
président s'est engagé cet après midi à
ce qu'il n'y ait pas de mise en
concurrence et donc il va york estimant
un bras de fer avec bruxelles à ce sujet
là avec la dg comtal à la commission
européenne mais il ya un engagement qui
a été pris parce que l'hydro électrique
c'est important il ya effectivement moi
je reçois leur foi des ong qui me
demande de faire des grands barrages ce
que c'est très bien et puis d'autres qui
disent non il faut pas de barrages parce
que c'est pas bon pour la biodiversité
donc il ya un peu d'incohérences là
dessus je suis d'accord edf n'est pas
ses billes avec des annonces qui sont
fait du rachat des turbines arabe et l
des alternateurs edf a maintenant
maîtriser toute la chaîne de valeur sur
la production nucléaire ce qui va lui
permettre d'avoir des partenaires aussi
avec d'autres pays dans le monde
d'autres animations le président de
république a cité d'ailleurs la russie
puisqu'il ya des désaccords très fort
encore aux atomes et les turbines arabe
elle qui fournissent déjà une partie
d'aidé des centrales nucléaires russes
donc il ya un travail de partenaires
d'affaires et sur le financement vous
avez oublié quelque chose il y à la
taxonomie européenne qui est là pour
amener des financements privés pour
pousser les projets nucléaires et qui
peut y avoir dans l'union européenne
donc on a aussi des leviers de
financement européen pour ses projets
nucléaires merci vaste des bars en tout
cas on le voit merci à tous les cadres
de brender anthony cabeke aux sélections
touzet et christophe grudler d'avoir
accepté donc d'être avec nous pour
décrypter ce discours réagir au discours
des manuels macro merci à vous et se
déplace sur belfort soulève des
interrogations le président était sur le
site de fabrication de turbines
nucléaires vendu il ya sept ans à
general electric tout un symbole pour le
chef de l'état qui en 2015 alors
ministre de l'économie avait accepté
qu'alstom le sait nos groupes américains
à guillemin aussi le rachat de la
filière nucléaire de general electric
par edf celle épilogue du moins on
l'espère d'un dossier vieux de plusieurs
années et qui entachent sérieusement le
bilan des manuels macro et de fait le
président de la république n'a pas
encore posé le pied à belfort que déjà
les critiques fusent emmanuel macron me
fait penser à un pyromane qui aurait
passé dix années a allumé au
lance-flammes des foyers un peu partout
et qui se met très tardivement en scène
comme un activiste forestier chez wwf
une motte de terre un arbre et une pelle
à la main macron ira jeudi à belfort
pour célébrer le rachat par edf des
turbines arabelle qu'il avait lui-même
bradé à general electric dans l'immense
camp d'alstom on ne peut rien macron a
passé son temps à brader notre industrie
justice sera faite
macron compte célébrer avec tambours et
trompettes le rachat de ce qu'il a bradé
depuis general electric à supprimer 3000
emplois nous n'avons pas besoin de
macron pour réparer ces dégâts la
branche énergies marines d'alstom cédés
à general electric doit être
nationalisées et les amendes payées
comptant et oui la vente de la branche
énergie d'alstom et notamment des
turbines arabes elles qui vont avec
c'est bien à l'actuel chef de l'état à
qu'on la doit mais manuel kron avait
supervisé le dossier lorsqu'il était
secrétaire général adjoint de l'elysée
avant d'autoriser la vente fin 2014
alors qu'il était ministre de l'économie
les turbines à vapeur arabelle on les
retrouve dans nos centrales nucléaires
dont nous sous marins ou encore dans le
porte avions charles de gaulle d'où les
réticences de l'époque a laissé passer
cette technologie sous pavillon
américain mais bercy s'était voulu
rassurant emmanuel mâcon s'est assurée
avec vigilance que les intérêts de
l'état la pérennité de la filière
nucléaire et la sécurisation de
l'approvisionnement énergétique de la
france sont pleinement pris en compte
dans cette opération en 2016 après le
rachat de general electric a suspendu le
travail de ses équipes de maintenance
dans les centrales pour forcer edf à
revoir le contrat d'entretien des
réacteurs et réduire la responsabilité
financière du groupe américain en cas
d'incident comme sauvegarde de la
souveraineté on a fait mieux mais
surtout general electric s'est assis
sans vergogne sur ses promesses
d'emplois aucun des 1000 postes prévues
n'aient vu le jour à la place ce sont
5000 personnes qui ont perdu leur
travail depuis la session d'alstom en
prenant en compte la sous traitance dont
1200 à belfort enfin avec l'arrestation
d'un des cadres dirigeants d'alstom aux
états unis en 2013 la vente du fleuron
français est depuis cité comme l'un des
exemples les plus frappants de la guerre
économique que les états unis livre même
à leurs alliés via l'extraterritorialité
du droit américain tout ça pour que
finalement general electric rendent le
bébé sept ans plus tard contre quelques
centaines de millions de dollars que va
devoir payer edf puisque c'est elle qui
récupère l'ancienne branche d'alstom un
peu contre son gré d'ailleurs une
intégration purement et simplement dans
edf comme le souhaite le gouvernement
n'est pas une solution edf n'a jamais
construit deux turbines ce n'est pas un
industriel sans compter que
l'électricien est déjà très endetté mais
qu'importe la stratégie énergétique du
gouvernement passe par le nucléaire en
nucléaire souverain qui plus est depuis
que l'exécutif s'est rendu compte des
dégâts que peut occasionner une crise de
l'approvisionnement en énergie comme
celle que nous vivons actuellement
personne n'avait vu venir la gravité de
cette crise énergétique a déclaré ce
mardi bruno le maire décidément entre ça
et la crise du coc vide l'anticipation
n'aura pas été le point fort des manuels
macron c'est sans doute ce qui le
contraint à venir réparer ce jeudi à
belfort les erreurs commises il ya sept
ans et les énergies tout un programme au
coeur de la campagne présidentielle le
pouvoir d'achat aussi à l'heure où
l'inflation monte en flèche d'après
l'insee la hausse des prix pourrait
atteindre 3 5% d'ici à cet été en
attendant les candidats y vont de leurs
propositions bien souvent axées sur la
hausse des salaires alors quelles
grandes tendances s'affrontent dans
cette campagne qui comprend le mieux les
attentes des français sur leur pouvoir
d'achat on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir seller
l'édito échos
[Musique]
les bons soirs jacques merci d'être avec
nous alors est ce que vous diriez sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat qu'elle est
importante voire décisive dans cette
campagne présidentielle ah oui elle sera
très certainement très importante avec
la question du pouvoir d'achat il ya
derrière évidemment le problème de
l'inflation alors on sait que
l'inflation augmente extrêmement vite
aux etats-unis +2 7% +2 5% en allemagne
on est quand même à plus de 3% en france
peut-être même 3,5 pour cent d'après ce
qu'annonce clint et ça aura évidemment
des conséquences sur le pouvoir d'achat
d'autant plus que le pouvoir d'achat et
ça on le sait il est en berne depuis
plusieurs années voire même des
décennies en france et donc il y aura un
véritable problème du pouvoir d'achat et
de l'inflation dans cette dans cette
élection alors à quoi elle est due cette
inflation alors l'inflation est en fait
due à trois facteurs tout d'abord il y à
la hausse de l'ensemble des matières
premières si vous voulez matières
premières agricoles les métaux le
pétrole
bref toutes les matières premières
augmente très fortement
ses billets à la sortie de la crise de
l'aco vie mais on voit quand même que
cette augmentation
elle est particulièrement forte pour
certains produits on a dépassé les plus
hauts que l'on avait connu en 2008 2009
donc ça c'est un premier point deuxième
point mais quand même et là avec le
discours d' emmanuel macron on est en
plein dans le sujet
les états ont lancé des grands
programmes d'investissement alors qu'il
s'agisse de refaire des infrastructures
comme en allemagne qu'il s'agisse de
préparer la transition énergétique comme
en france avec le développement
justement de l'industrie nucléaire bref
tout cela crée un contexte qui est
désormais un contexte clairement
inflationnistes et puis il ya une
troisième du nom et un troisième facteur
qui lui est beaucoup plus spécifique à
la france c'est le fait que en réalité
pendant la crise de l'aco vie il ya eu
une baisse de la productivité or qui dit
baisse de la productivité dit
nécessairement hausse des coûts alors on
peut dire bon d'accord la productivité
va repartir de l'avant oui mais il
faudra plusieurs trimestres voire
plusieurs semestre pour que l'on arrive
à nouveau à un niveau équivalent à celui
de 2010 9,7 inflation elle arrive quand
même au plus mauvais moment pour le
gouvernement
oui ah oui tout à fait on est en pleine
période électorale on comprend on
comprend effectivement est d'autant plus
qu'il ya plusieurs problèmes alors tout
d'abord vous avez le problème c'est que
la hausse des prix elle n'est pas
ressentie de la même manière dans les
différentes catégories de la population
les disons les plus pauvres les trois
premiers déciles ils ressentent une
inflation qui est supérieure à la
moyenne les plus riches les deux ou
trois premiers dernier décile ils
ressentent une inflation qui est
nettement inférieur à la moyenne on le
voit d'ailleurs sur le graphique qui
s'affiche à l'écran et qu'est ce que ça
veut dire comme le smic en particulier
il est calculé par rapport à la moyenne
ressenti de l'inflation eh bien ça veut
dire que les trois premiers déciles ils
perdent régulièrement 2 grosso modo 1998
à 2015 sur ce tableau ils perdent
réguler herman du pouvoir d'achat alors
ça c'est un premier problème deuxième
problème où se situe justement cette
inflation cette hausse des prix bientôt
situe essentiellement sur des produits
qui sont tout à fait cruciaux pour les
budgets des classes moyennes et si vous
voulez aider des gens les plus pauvres
c'est quoi c'est le transport le
carburant pour le transport pour le
chauffage aussi mais c'est aussi les
produits alimentaires donc ça ça fait un
deuxième problème est le troisième
problème est bien c'est que globalement
le pouvoir d'achat de certaines
catégories de la population je pense par
exemple aux enseignants je pense au
personnel infirmier bon pour prendre des
cas vraiment archétypique qui sont le
plus connu dans l'opinion et bien dans
ces catégories en réalité le pouvoir
d'achat a perdu depuis une vingtaine
d'années des montants considérables donc
c'est la combinaison de ces trois
facteurs qui rend cette espèce de
démarrage de l'inflation actuelle qui le
rend tout à fait explosif pour la
question du pouvoir d'achat alors la
question c'est comment réagissent les
candidats à commencer par le presque on
va l'appeler comme ça le presque
candidat emmanuel macron alors le
presque candidat emmanuel macron et bien
il fait une analyse que vous rejoindre
cette inflation va être une inflation
transitoire qui ne durera que quelques
mois ce en quoi je pense qu'ils se
trompent et donc qu'est ce qui lie bas
il suffit de donner des primes la
fameuse prime dite anti inflation ou
alors il suffit de bloquer quelques prix
en sachant qu'on ne pourra pas maintenir
ce blocage très longtemps oui mais
qu'est ce qui va se passer si justement
cette inflation perdure et c'est ce que
j'ai expliqué avec ce contexte
d'investissements qui est en train de se
mettre en place dans l'ensemble des pays
d'europe d'ailleurs pas pas simplement
qu'en france est bien là il dit bon le
retour à l'emploi ça va d'une certaine
manière permettre aux gens de gagner
plus et donc ça va leur permettre
d'absorber ce choc d'inflation sauf que
ce retour à l'emploi actuellement ces
six cent mille personnes sur 6 5
millions de demandeurs d'emploi moins de
10% donc on voit bien que la il ya un
véritable problème qui n'est pas couvert
par le discours où là je dirais la
programmatique du gouvernement et du
président et pour les autres candidats
alors pour les autres candidats c'est
très intéressant parce qu'on voit qu'il
ya en fait deux philosophies qui
s'opposent complètement alors je prends
d'abord les gens qui ont font en fait à
peu près la même analyse qu emmanuel
macron même s'ils ne le disent pas
madame valérie pécresse monsieur eric
zemmour qu'est ce qu'ils vivent et 10
des primes exactement ce que fait manuel
en cours et puis disent oui on va
augmenter le salaire net en supprimant
les charges patronales sauf que qu'est
ce que c'est que les charges passées des
cotisations en réalité qu'ils ont pas
payés par le salarié qui sont payés par
le patron qu'est ce que ça veut dire ces
cotisations elles servent à alimenter le
système social français autrement dit si
vous voulez retirer de la fiche de paie
c'est très bien pour le salarié mais ça
voudra dire qu'il faudra lui reprendre
cet argent que ce soit par l'impôt ou
par d'autres moyens d'un autre côté donc
on voit bien là qu'il y à un véritable
problème structurel est en réalité qu
est-ce que ce qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que pour ces deux candidats
ils ont essentiellement dans la ligne de
mire la question de la compétitivité
française ce qui n'est pas faux mais il
raisonne comme si nous devions rester ad
vitam aeternam dans le cadre de l'euro
l'élection qui se jouera donc bel et
bien sur cette question du pouvoir
d'achat oui et ça se voit aussi avec les
autres candidats si vous voulez alors on
a d'autres candidats comme par exemple
marine le pen jean-luc mélenchon qui
d'une certaine manière on peut être pris
plus conscience du phénomène
inflationniste qui se passe et là on le
voit très bien ils veulent à la fois des
quelques primes ils veulent surtout des
hausses pérenne des salaires nous avons
aussi fabien roussel le candidat du pcr
qui dit à peu de choses près la même la
même chose et puis nous avons anne
hidalgo qui avait promis rappelez-vous
ce doublement du salaire des enseignants
en un mandat et dire qu'on ne sait même
pas assez ça doublement net sa fin c'est
un double au champ en salaires réels ou
où ce sera mangée par l'inflation bref
il ya des cons dit quand ces fouilles et
il y aura quand même d'autres sujets qui
vont peser sur cette campagne jacques
oui oui il y aura certainement d'autres
sujets mais il faut comprendre une chose
c'est que la question du pouvoir d'achat
et la question de l'inflation c'est au
coeur actuellement des préoccupations
des français c'est très intéressant on
voit par exemple que dans les derniers
sondages la question de l'immigration la
question de la sécurité ont reculé par
rapport à la question justement du
pouvoir d'achat et de l'inflation et
donc même si ça ne sera pas la seule
question dans fat dont on va débattre
dans cette campagne c'est évident ça
sera une question absolument centrale
dans les débats et tout candidat qui
l'oublieraient risques créés justement
de l'oublier à ses propres dépens merci
beaucoup jacques pour cette mise en
garde et à la semaine prochaine
et pendant que certains ménages tente de
boucler tendance mal leurs fins de mois
les entreprises du cac 40 soutenu par
l'état durant la crise du coc bid
affiche des profits historiques en 2021
total énergie chez qui les milliers
arabes ont d'augmenter fortement ses
tarifs versent des dividendes à
profusion mais ne laisse que des miettes
aux autres on voit cela avec 4,6 à pique
nique en 2021 les entreprises françaises
cotées en bourse ont réalisé des profits
records des chiffres historiques pour
certaines bnp paribas affiche 9,5
milliards d'euros de bénéfices 16,1 pour
cent de plus qu'en 2010 9 tandis que
lvmh a engrangé 12 milliards d'euros
ainsi que 6,3 milliards pour sanofi est
totale à total rebaptisé total énergie
au pluriel pour être moins catalogué
pétrole énergies fossiles et bien
l'accompagner engrangé 15 milliards
c'est le montant le plus haut depuis 15
ans en tout on parle de prévisions de
137 milliards d'euros de profits en 2021
71 % de plus qu'en 2019 mais pas de quoi
pavoiser cette réussite s'appuie bien
sûr le rebond attendu
la mort aux années 2020 est également
largement sur les aides de l'état la
france a ainsi accordé 240 milliards aux
sociétés via les aides et le plan de
relance dont une partie a été dirigée
vers ces grandes entreprises lesquels
pour la plupart se sont empressés de
verser des dividendes à leurs
actionnaires
alors même que la ministre du travail
mme muriel pénicaud avait incité à la
retenue il faut aussi considérer que les
aides massives étaient assorties de
contreparties en matière de partage des
richesses de protection de l'emploi de
l'environnement alors que de nombreuses
entreprises du cac 40 ont engagé des
plans sociaux ou non licenciés mais
revenons sur un cas d'école total
énergie à cause de la flambée des prix
du baril du gaz les os des factures
d'énergie de carburant sont une tragédie
pour certains consommateurs saluons
alors le geste noble de total qui s'est
sacrifié patrick pouyanné son pdg a
annoncé un chèque de 100 euros pour 200
mille ménages précaires et 5 euros de
réduction pour un plein de 50 litres
dans mille 150 stations services en zone
rurale mais seulement pendant trois mois
vous êtes trop bon monseigneur sauf que
cette petite elle est en réalité une
tartufferie elles représentent moins de
0 4 % des bénéfices engrangés par total
et cela ne passe pas chez les ong
environnementales ni chez les politiques
totalement que les prix de l'essence en
caisse 15 milliards de profits et parce
qu'il fait une opération de pub à 5
euros offerts pour 50 des pensées il
faut lui dire merci ça va pas la tête ça
me fait penser aux voleurs qui te pique
ta voiture mais torrent l'allume-cigare
le bénéfice net de total et de monsieur
puyané ces 15 milliards d'euros cette
année sur le dos des françaises et des
français les factures de gaz et
d'essence qui augmente c'est au profit
des actionnaires les ristournes promises
par total leur coûteront 50 millions
d'euros soit 0 33 % de leurs 15
milliards de bénéfices et il faudrait se
mettre à genoux mains jointes merci pour
le mode monseigneur non blocage des
dividendes blocage des prix ces 15
milliards d'euros sont à nous et les
politiques de tickets sur les dividendes
distribués par total energy 7,1
milliards à ses actionnaires en 2021
soit la moitié du profit réalisé les
entreprises du cac 40 aurait distribué
aux actionnaires près de 70 milliards
d'euros en 2021 sous forme de dividendes
ou de rachats d'actions un record
historique mais les salariés aurait-il
bénéficier d'une quelconque largesses au
vu de ces profits pharamineux et bien
sans surprise pas vraiment total qui
comptait supprimer plusieurs centaines
de postes en france fin 2020 a bien
augmenté les salaires de 3 5% en 2022
par exemple mais pour les moins payés
cette hausse conséquente n'est pas
significative bnp n'a augmenté ses
employés que de 0,6 pour cent préférant
accorder des primes et intéressement en
fait la théorie du ruissellement c'est
merveilleux c'est juste que dans une
formidable offense à la gravité le
liquide remonte massivement vers le haut
vers les plus riches laissant les
millions de pauvres à sec
emmanuel macron toujours donné gagnant
au premier tour de la présidentielle
alors d'un selon un sondage est là bas
alors que valérie pécresse a perdu un
point dans les intentions de vote
l'ancien ministre eric woerth président
l ère de la commission des finances de
l'assemblée nationale a décidé de
soutenir emmanuel macron nicolas sarkozy
ne se prononce pas encore sur la
candidate elle erre dans le figaro
l'ancien président de la république
décrit une candidate inexistante dans la
campagne présidentielle en écoute
valérie part dans tous les sens déjà si
dans une campagne tu arrives à imprimer
une ou deux idées c'est un miracle il
faut marteler en permanence en 2007 on
parlait de sarko matin midi et soir mais
là qui parle de valérie pécresse et les
inexistante et pour revenir sur cette
actualité politique nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec eric revel éditorialistes
rt france alors éric mauvaise séquence
pour valérie pécresse qui non seulement
n'a toujours pas le soutien tant attendu
nicolas sarkozy c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire mais en plus elle récolte
quelques critiques un petit peu acide la
fin mars mais vous connaissez sans doute
l'expression ça plus comme à gravelotte
ça signifie que sap ledru alors moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est que les coups
pleuvent sur valérie pécresse en ce
moment
il ya évidemment cette déclaration au
figaro de nicolas sarkozy qui tacle 1 on
peut dire valérie pécresse qui la
trouvent insignifiantes qui estiment
qu'elle ne prime pas qu'ils la trouvent
trop techno qui considère qu'elle ne
cite que jacques chirac alors que c'est
lui nicolas sarkozy rappelle t-il au
figaro qui l'a fait ministre pendant
cinq ans donc les coûts sont dru et ce
qui ne manque pas de sel c'est que cette
interview de nicolas sarkozy est sorti
alors que demain nicolas sarkozy et
valérie pécresse se voit dans les
bureaux de l'ancien par exemple la
république mais les coups pleuvent sans
discontinuer depuis plusieurs jours vous
avez parlé du ralliement d'eric woerth
ancien ministre du budget de nicolas
sarkozy président de la commission des
finances qui passe donc avec armes et
bagages du côté des manuels macron on
peut aussi parler de la charge
incroyable de rachida dati la garde des
sceaux garde des sceaux de nicolas
sarkozy comme par hasard qui elle trouve
que le directeur de campagne de valérie
pécresse je cite est un looser stéphanie
donc tous ces coups arrive évidemment en
même temps sans doute quelques jours
avant qu emmanuel macron ne se déclare
c'est une mauvaise séquence pour valérie
pécresse les ralliements vont peut-être
se poursuivre dit on du côté des
républicains en direction d' emmanuel
macron par exemple un maire important en
france le maire de saint-etienne gaël
perdriau qui annonçait alors qu'il est
républicain et l'air qu'il ne
pardonnerait pas la candidature de
valérie pécresse je voulais dit ça pleut
comme à gravelotte d'autant plus que
valérie pécresse est en difficulté dans
les sondages certains sondages la
donnent au coude à coude maintenant avec
eric zemmour donc la grande difficulté
est évidemment c'est que valérie
pécresse ne se fasse pas siphonné une
partie de son électorat maintenant par
eric zemmour le grand vainqueur de tout
ça évidemment comme par hasard ce serait
le candidat non déclaré emmanuel macron
qui réussirent est une sorte de grand
strike 1 comme on dit au bowling parce
que si évidemment il arrivait une
catastrophe électorale à valérie
pécresse il détruirait un peu plus les
républicains en faisant peut-être monter
la droite nationale et donc tout bénef
politique pour le chef de l'état eric
revel une question à vous entendre
pourquoi tant de haine justement vous
l'avez dit ici eric zemmour a d'ailleurs
il était là on le voit dans le sondage
dont on parlait 14h30 aujourd'hui contre
15 pour valérie pécresse selon pécresse
selon l'institut ifop quel intérêt ont
les républicains a siphonné à savenay
autant la planche leur candidate alors
je vais travestir il me le pardonnera le
général de gaulle qui disait les états
n'ont pas d'amis n'ont que des intérêts
en politique la politique n'a pas d'amis
elle n'a que des intérêts en réalité
valérie pécresse est un peu sur le fil
du rasoir on sent bien que ça peut être
un point de bascule elle j'ai une très
gros 1 dimanche elle va tenir un meeting
à paris au zénith
c'est un tournant la campagne électorale
pour elle est évidemment tout ça n'est
pas un hasard jacques chirac son mentor
puisqu'elle le site plus souvent que
nicolas sarkozy jacques chirac disait
les emmerdes ça arrive en escadrille est
bien le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
que les escadrilles vol dans le ciel
orageux de la campagne électorale de
valérie pécresse et c'est peut-être pas
terminée elle peut encore s'en sortir
une campagne électorale n'est jamais
terminé dans les 15 derniers jours on a
vu sur les campagnes précédentes défaits
sociétaux des actes des déclarations qui
peuvent plomber ou au contraire faire
que le candidat en difficulté trouve un
tremplin pour se rétablir mais en
réalité on sait aussi c'est souvent en
février début mars qu'une campagne
politique présidentielle se
cristallisent en france
évidemment je le dis parce que je le
pense cela n'arrive pas par hasard au
moment où ça arrive ce tir croisé sur
valérie pécresse c'est sans doute une
volonté peut-être essayer d'abattre la
candidate valérie pécresse alors on peut
aussi en toute objectivité trouvé que la
tonalité
des meeting de valérie pécresse est
prise de parole ces idées qui
s'entrechoquent et qu'il imprime pas
forcément sont un véritable handicap est
ce que patrick stefanini son directeur
de campagne traité de looser par rachida
dati arrivera à corriger le tir et à
permettre comme lille lionel jospin
ancien premier ministre socialiste
qu'elle fonde l'armure les prochains
jours nous le diront en tout cas il y en
a un qui profitent de tout ça qui boite
certainement du petit lait le président
français toujours pas déclaré manuel
maintenant qu'ils bénéficient on en
parle souvent mais enfin c'est vrai que
là on le voit séquence internationale
pour emmanuel macron face à vladimir
poutine aujourd'hui encore une heure de
temps d'antenne non-stop sur les chaînes
en continu c'est l'état de grâce mais en
tout cas c'est un candidat non déclaré
qui fait campagne sur le sujet
d'aujourd'hui tout ça ne manque pas de
sel parce que le même emmanuel macron
ministre des finances qui avait vendu
toute la branche énergie d'alstom à
l'américain jim a fait volte face on
peut le dire sur la question du
nucléaire lorsqu'il était dans la
commission attali avant même d'être
ministre de l'économie il était plutôt
anti nucléaire et le voilà devenu pro
nucléaire il annonce la création de
réacteurs il annonce le rachat d'une
toute petite partie d'alstom sur l'esl
et les turbines nucléaires il veut de
nouveau développer la filière nucléaire
en additionnant edf framatome et cette
petite partie d'alstom le voici en
sauveur de l'énergie voilà l'ère la
salle lui alors que lui il avait enfoncé
s'avère décidément c'est comme ça qu'on
valait près cette semaine merci en tout
cas eric revel rester avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlons du
traitement d'air tesfran sur le dossier
de la crise ukrainienne pointé du doigt
par certains de nos confrères dont ce
papier publié sur rt france en pas moins
d'une semaine
lui consacre notre décryptage
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres la corruption la profonde
criminalité des états unis et de leurs
alliés de l'otan
ce sa page de réputation qui a commencé
quasiment immédiatement après la
publication des irakiens warlocks
l'isolent de la société
le new york times
le washington post the guardian
der spiegel hugo
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment je dirais déçu
oui mais pas surpris
[Musique]
en 2010 il y avait environ 200
satellites en orbite en 2021 on en
compte quatre mille et en 2030 il y en
aura plus de 100 milles autour de la
terre le secteur spatial est un domaine
stratégique
où les plus grandes puissances se
livrent une guerre économique
territoriale et militaire essentiel de
laventure c'est pas tellement laventure
scientifique mais c'est d'abord une
recherche de supériorité stratégique
rien n'est simple car les intérêts sont
divergents et la concurrence totale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire l'axé l'ukrainienne avec la
poursuite du ballet diplomatique
aujourd'hui c'est la ministre
britannique des affaires étrangères qui
s'est entretenu avec son homologue russe
à moscou le premier ministre britannique
est lui à bruxelles pour rencontrer le
patron de l'otan des discussions tout
continue alors que les populations
s'inquiètent pour la suite on retrouvera
notre envoyé spécial dans quelques
instants depuis le dombass il y à la
rencontre de ceux qui vivent depuis des
aînés au rythme de la guerre
le traitement d'air t sur le dossier
ukrainien justement pointé du doigt par
certains de nos confrères douce papier
publié sur rt france en pas moins d'une
semaine dont tu as dans lequel on
apprend qu'une antenne de l'art comme le
nouveau nom du csa a été lancé à
l'origine de cette saisine une seule
association médias démocratique europe
qui créent et qui a été créé il ya à
peine quelques mois
[Musique]
le dossier ukrainien concentre donc
toujours l'attention de la communauté
internationale la russie a lancé
aujourd'hui la deuxième série
d'exercices militaires conjoints avec la
biélorussie la france et l'ukraine ont
fait part de leur mécontentement
l'europe toute entière se prépare à une
intervention militaire entre discours et
actions sur le terrain la situation
reste sous haute tension
hélène escaliers
le ballet diplomatique qui s'opère entre
moscou et les capitales occidentales est
étourdissant l'objectif affiché
désamorcer la crise boris johnson va à
bruxelles pour rencontrer le secrétaire
général de l'otan avant de partir pour
la pologne pendant ce temps sa ministre
des affaires étrangères li strauss elle
se rend à moscou elle s'est entretenue
avec son homologue russe appelant le
kremlin a retiré ses troupes près des
frontières l'ukrainienne un dialogue
qualifié de sourds par le ministre russe
des affaires étrangères
pour être honnête je suis déçu qu'on est
une conversation qui soit un dialogue de
sourds on entend mais on ne s'écoute pas
du moins nos explications détaillées
sont arrivés sur un terrain mal préparée
c'est à peu près la même chose quand on
dit que la russie attend que le sol gèle
et deviennent durs comme la pierre pour
que les chars puissant très calmement
sur le territoire ukrainien il me semble
que c'était ce même terrain chez nos
collègues britanniques aujourd'hui
à bruxelles le discours des britanniques
et ferme pour boris johnson les
prochains jours constitueront le moment
le plus dangereux il estime que la crise
ukrainienne est la plus grande crise de
sécurité à laquelle l'europe a été
confrontée des échanges se déroulent
aussi à berlin du chancelier olaf scholz
reçoit les dirigeants des pays baltes le
front oriental de l'europe
dans cette situation critique pour nous
tous la russie ne devrait pas
sous-estimer notre unité notre
détermination
en tant que partenaire au sein de lieux
et en tant qu'allié au sein de l'otan
des discours qui peinent à apaiser les
tensions derrière la diplomatie sur le
terrain on se prépare et l'europe place
ses pions des parachutistes américains
sont déployés en pologne tandis que
boris johnson annonce l'envoi de trois
cent cinquante soldats de plus dans le
pays et se dit prêt à en mobiliser 1000
supplémentaires hasard du calendrier le
danemark ouvre de son côté ses portes à
l'armée américaine
copenhague signé un nouvel accord
bilatéral avec les états unis pour
faciliter la circulation de ses troupes
sur le territoire européen
ce n'est pas la crise autour de
l'ukraine et des frontière ukrainienne
qui est à l'origine de cette décision
mais il est en même temps évident que la
situation en ukraine est une
illustration très clair que nous ne
pouvons pas prendre notre liberté notre
pays notre sécurité pour acquise
un premier convoi transportant de
l'équipement militaire des etats-unis
destiné aux mille soldats américains qui
doivent se déployer en roumanie est
entrée dans le pays bucarest se dit
déterminé à remplir ses engagements
conformément aux décisions prises au
sein de l'otan l'engagement de ces pays
de l'est aux côtés de l'alliance
atlantique sur le flanc oriental
européen constitue justement l'une des
principales pommes de discorde avec la
russie
et alors que le ballet diplomatique se
poursuit donc sur la situation en
ukraine les habitants s'inquiètent pour
leur avenir ce soir nous allons
justement à la rencontre des premiers
concernés se vivent toujours dans le
combat de ces deux régions dévastées par
la guerre on retrouve sur place notre
correspondante one claireaux bonsoir
antoine
on veut donc à donetsk comment les
habitants vivent la situation actuelle
oui stéphanie et bien justement nous
sommes allés à la rencontre de la
population leur rencontre de ses
habitants de john yates alors bien
entendu les gens sont préoccupés parce
qu'ils peuvent lire dans les journaux ou
encore voir à la télévision la presse
occidentale relais depuis des semaines d
information sur l'imminence d'une
invasion de l'ukraine par la russie mais
les gens ici craignent davantage une
offensive de la part de kiev que les
services de renseignement russes au
passage juge plausible car en effet la
ligne de front se trouve simplement à
quelques kilomètres d'ici écoutez
nous sommes sous pression constante tous
les jours nous entendons des tirs soit
ce sont nos hommes qui ripostent soit ce
sont les autres qui tire bien sûr on ne
peut pas le savoir avec certitude
on le comprend seulement quand quelque
chose tombe ici à proximité on reste
chez nous bien sûr par exemple je reste
toujours derrière le mur j'ai la cuisine
la salle de bain et les toilettes et il
y à un mur de l'autre côté je suis
toujours là et quand ça commence je
cours là dans le petit couloir ça fait
très peur j'ai peur pour les enfants
pour les plus vieux j'ai peur pour tout
le monde
les autres ont confiance dans les forces
des républiques autoproclamées de
donetsk et de lougansk pour les protéger
ou bien encore celle de la russie ont
coûté
personnellement je n'ai aucune crainte
car je crois fermement que si un moment
difficile arrive la russie nous aidera
toujours comme elle l'a déjà fait
plusieurs fois et nous avons quand même
de vrais hommes dans l'armée je connais
ses combattants c'est pas comme au début
donc je pense que tout cela n'est qu'une
façade très soigneusement mise en scène
par quelqu'un et que vous savez tout
ressemble à un décor c'est ce qui me
semble en tout cas
donc à quoi pense à mca patate au japon
nous avons peur parce que nous élevons
des enfants ici ils apprennent à vivre
alors bien sûr nous avons peur depuis
2014 mais nous croyons en la russie la
russie nous aidera nous croyons en nos
soldats nous espérons le meilleur en
route
même si dans la ville de dounia ce que
la vie reste calme la population du nom
basse vit depuis des années maintenant
au rythme d'une guerre au rythme d'une
guerre de basse intensité et qui fait
toujours régulièrement des morts et ce à
quelques kilomètres d'ici et en cas
d'escaladé militaire tous ces gens le
savent ils se retrouveront alors en
première ligne merci antoine perreault
en direct depuis donné est merci à vous
et justement 12 papier publié sur rt
france en une semaine dont un dans
lequel on apprend qu'une enquête de
l'art comme nouveau nom du csa a été
lancée dernier article en date celui de
libération indiquant qu arte france est
dans l'oeil du gendarme de l'audiovisuel
article dans lequel il y a d'ailleurs
beaucoup de détails dans cette crise
ukrainienne et le traitement par rt
france on en parle avec un jérôme bonnet
rédacteur en chef du site web d'arte et
france bonsoir jérôme merci d'être avec
nous tout d'abord comment avez vous
appris la saisine de l'art comme un
nouveau nom pour le csa vient
paradoxalement c'est par la presse honda
a pris puisque effectivement c'est dans
le challenge qui annoncé cette saisine
est donc effectivement on a contacté
naturellement nos services ont contacté
l'art comme pour leur demander ce qu'il
en était il nous a été répondu de ne pas
nous inquiéter qu'effectivement il
reconnaissait bien être saisi et disait
pas par qui pourquoi il disait on va
examiner les éléments qui sont portés à
notre connaissance et s'il ya matière à
notre sens nous reviendrons vers vous
c'est à ce moment là que nous recevons
de deux journalistes de libération une
série de questions et e pour le coup
semble vraiment très très bien informés
sur la procédure en cours et surtout sur
qui a lancé cette saisine auprès de
l'arcade c'est à dire cette fameuse aux
sessions médias démocratie liberté on a
envie de vous poser c'est qu'ils sont
ces gens eh bien oui et alors on sait
tout de suite effectivement poser
exactement cette question stéphanie
alors on m'a regardé et sur internet on
n'a rien trouvé du tout quelqu'un de
curieux pour une association alors on
regarde le journal officiel et on
s'aperçoit que l à huit mois d'existence
elle a été créée en juin dernier alors
lui moi c'est à la fois court dans la
vie d'une association mais c'est lumpur
n'avoir strictement rien fait parce que
si on regarde sur internet encore une
fois y'a pas un communiqué il n'y a
vraiment rien et donc on se demandait un
peu ce qu'était cette inflation cas
ressemble quand même à une coquille vide
et puis on avait trouvé la trace
également de leur adresse mail immeuble
ou ici sont parisiens où ils sont censés
se trouver il ya rien qui est alors non
feinte c'était vraiment très étrange et
puis à ce moment là donc paraît ce
fameux article de libération et là on en
apprend un petit peu plus sur eux alors
qu'elle n'a pas écarté et bien
effectivement c'est essayer étrange
parce que
on voit que c'est une association
dont le vice-président et un lituanien
qui regroupe une dizaine de citoyens
issus d'europe de l'est et on se demande
un peu pourquoi cette soudaine passion
pour le paysage audiovisuel français et
ben en fait les seuls éléments qu'on a
dans libération qui permettent de
développer une théorie c'est que ces
gens se disent ouvertement anti kremlin
donc peut-être pense-t-il au travers de
rt france atteindre la russie ce qui est
un peu ridicule mais c'est les gens de
le penser alors pourquoi commencer
justement par la france eh ben ça c'est
assez intéressant stéphanie parce que ce
qu'ils disent c'est qu'ils ont trouvé il
dit vouloir toucher toutes les antennes
de retirer 10 on espère que l'initiative
fera tâche d'huile dans les autres pays
européens donc il s'agit bien de
d'attaquer toutes les antennes de rtl
néanmoins pourquoi la france parce que
selon leurs termes ils y ont trouvé le
contexte alors elle qui excusez moi le
terme barbare que juridico administratif
le plus probable alors qu'est ce que ça
veut dire juridico administratif à mon
avis pour ce qui est de l'administratif
c'est peut-être que le gouvernement
français n'a jamais caché son hostilité
envers un thé france donc un contexte
favorable de ce point de vue là et pour
le côté juridique qui a évidemment la
loi anti fait qu news je rappelle que
cette loi a été dénoncé à l'assemblée
lors de son adoption par certains
députés notamment jean luc mélenchon qui
disait qu'il s'agissait sous couvert de
paul haute d information d'attaquer
directement certains médias dont rt
france et là les choses sont très
claires pas tout à fait injustement
c'est pas clair du tout merci enfin
votre rubrique était clair mais ce qu on
y lit effectivement n'est pas toujours
très clair merci jérôme un bonnet
rédacteur en chef d'arte et français
s'est attaquée injustement dans la
presse française et larry elle arrive
dans un contexte un petit peu
particulier ça ne doit pas échapper
celui de la crise diplomatique autour de
l'ukraine une crise dans laquelle les
états unis sont partie prenante ceci
expliquant sans doute pourquoi le
traitement cette crise par rt intéresse
de près peut-être l'administration
américaine le département américain a
publié un rapport sur le groupe rt pour
en parler on retrouve thomas bonnet à
washington bonsoir thomas vous êtes donc
à notre correspondant à washington que
dit ce rapport
et bien c'est un rapport qui a donc été
publié par le département d'état
américain l'équivalent ici du ministère
des affaires étrangères et ce rapport a
en réalité été rédigé par le global
language mann center dont la mission est
selon leur présentation officielle de je
cite coordonner les efforts pour
permettre au gouvernement américain de
comprendre et de contrer la
désinformation d'état étrangers qui
viserait à saper la stabilité et la
sécurité des états unis et de leurs
alliés
alors cet organisme s'était déjà
intéressé en 2020 à ce qui était
présenté à l'époque comme un écosystème
de désinformation de la russie et le
rapport paru ces derniers jours et
auquel on s'intéresse aujourd'hui se
focalise plus spécifiquement sur rt et
scout nique et le rôle supposé dans ce
système de propagande car c'est le terme
qui est employé dans ce rapport alors ce
document d'une antenne de pages
répertorie toutes les accusations que
l'on connaît depuis longtemps maintenant
à savoir que rt et scout nick serait par
nature très différent des autres médias
occidentaux qui sont également financés
par des états le texte justifie cette
affirmation notamment par une opacité en
matière de budget et d'organisation on y
vit aussi que les rédactions recevrait
des ordres directs de moscou le rapport
s'appuie notamment sur des témoignages
d'anciens salariés qui ont quitté
l'entreprise alors sur le fond le texte
affirme que rt scouts nick serve de
caisse de résonance sur les sujets
importants pour le kremlin le traitement
éditorial de la pandémie est notamment
utilisée comme argument pour expliquer
que rt et spoutnik aurait eu pour but de
saper la confiance entre les citoyens et
leurs gouvernements en exposant par
exemple les divisions entre les pays
alliés européens pendant la gestion de
la crise sanitaire tout en faisant
toujours selon le même texte la
promotion du vaccin spoutnik au
détriment des autres vaccins un thomas
quelles sont les conclusions tirées par
les américains sur
rtc bien selon ses auteurs il est clair
que rt spoutnik ne sont en rien
comparable avec les autres médias le
rapport affirme que ces médias agissent
comme des messagers de la propagande et
de la désinformation du kremlin je vais
vous lire les dernières lignes de la
conclusion de ce rapport parce qu'elle
parle d'elle-même je cite donc le
kremlin utilisent ces médias dans une
tentative d'obtenir à davantage
politique quand la vérité n'avantage pas
à la russie le kremlin a utilisé ces
médias pour s'immiscer dans les
élections saper la démocratie est
menacée l'ordre international fondé sur
des règles vous l'aurez compris on fait
donc face à un niveau d'accusation
particulièrement élevé et que l'on a
malheureusement déjà pu entendre dans
les propos de certains dirigeants
occidentaux
est thomas ce rapport cite en référence
les travaux d'un chercheur français
maxime au dîner 1 de l'école militaire
de la défense à ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire plus
oui en effet son travail est citée deux
fois parmi les 10 zen d'un ex que compte
le rapport alors maxime au dîner est un
chercheur spécialisé sur la russie et
qui a publié récemment un livre consacré
à rt1 médias au service de l'état russe
selon lui maxime au dîner qui
travaillent donc au sein de l'ircem un
institut de recherche de l'école
militaire au sein du ministère français
des armées rappelez vous en 2018 l'irsn
s'étaient d'ailleurs intéressé aux
manipulations de l'information il y
avait publié et remis un rapport à la
ministre des armées florence parly ce
rapport était principalement consacrée à
la russie et notamment à rt notons pour
finir que le directeur de l'irsn chargé
de ce rapport dont de 2018 est également
membre du think tank atlantic council
qui a pour but entre autres de
promouvoir les liens entre les
etats-unis et les pays européens merci
thomas bonnet en direct de washington et
maxime au dîner que l'on a évidemment
contacté aujourd'hui afin qu'ils
viennent étayer son point de vue sur
notre plateau a décliné cette invitation
renvoyant à son ouvrage pour toute
explication c'est donc sans lui que nous
allons revenir avec nos invités sur
quelques points soulevés afin d'exprimer
également le point de vue des rdt et
france peu ou pas pris en compte par ses
détracteurs il faut bien le dire place à
notre décryptage avec nos invités
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler david koubbi
avocat en direct avec nous donc régis le
sommier également grand reporter rt
france bonsoir à tous les deux sur ce
plateau des bides l'eau comme sociologue
historien des médias bonsoir david ce
colloque merci d'être avec nous sur ce
plateau je me tourne tout d'abord vers
l'homme de droit pour commencer david
koubbi ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'on jette la suspicion sur rt france a
de cette manière qu en est-il vraiment
est-ce qu arte france a déjà été
sanctionné
alors vous avez raison de le beau soir
dont vous avez raison de préciser non ce
n'est pas la première fois que une
suspicion de la sorte est jeté sur sur
votre média sur votre chaîne rtl france
et les suspicions pour reprendre le
terme que vous indiquez la sont jetés à
plusieurs égards c'est à dire qu'elles
le sont de manière juridique vous en
parlait c'était votre sujet précédent et
de ce que j'en comprends l'objet de
notre débat donc une saisine de
l'autorité de régulation avant le csa
maintenant l'art comme mais il y a en
parallèle un
comment puis je dire que ça
d'environnement qui est fait autour
d'air t qui concerne un environnement
politique et notamment vous le savez
vous vous en mettre fait l'écho un
certain nombre de reprises sur notre sur
notre antenne
vos journalistes sont interdits de
conférence de presse de la république en
marche et sont interdits de conférence
de presse de l'elysée maintenant que
emmanuel macron a été élu quand je dis
maintenant c'est évidemment depuis 2010
est quand je dis qu'ils sont interdits
c'est évidemment un abus de langage dans
la mesure où il n'y a pas d'interdiction
que nous pourrions combattre
juridiquement d'une manière ou d'une
autre ce qu'il y assez simplement une
multitude une palanquée de demandes qui
sont restés soit lettre morte soit
auquel il vous a été répondu et je
connais assez bien ce sujet qu'il n'y
avait pas de place qu'elle n'avait pas
été fait dans les bordels et serra alors
qu' il y a la place et qu'elles ont été
faits dans les bons délais dont voilà
qu'elle est l'environnement d'ensemble
pour les personnes qui vous regardent
pour vos téléspectateurs afin qu'il
comprenne bien où se situe rt par
rapport au pouvoir en place français et
s'agissant des sanctions à proprement
parler non il n'y en a pas eu vous le
savez bien il y a eu une mise en demeure
cette mise en demeure qui a été adressé
par l'ancêtre de marque comme c'est à
dire le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel le csa
a fait l'objet d'une notification de
griefs et cette notification de griefs a
quant à elle fait l'objet d'un abandon
total de toute critique à l'endroit de
votre chaîne par une décision qui a été
rendue en février 2001 le 26 février
2020 pour être précis ailleurs était
habituel maître koubbi d'apprendre par
voie de presse cette enquête est ce que
c'est la procédure courante
jeu
j'espère que vous êtes en train
d'agoniser évidemment que ça n'est pas
courant évidemment que ça n'est pas la
procédure courante on peut même dire que
c'est une anomalie puisque ces enquêtes
sont entourés dans secret à l'instar du
droit pénal par exemple que l'on appelle
le soutien de la requête ou le secret de
l'instruction il est totalement
incongrue par un congrès je veux dire
des places est anormal
non usuelle d'apprendre par la presse
quand on dit la presse et 1 500 au large
ça veut dire par vos confrères d'autres
médias en l'occurrence challenge et
libération le journal libération qui a
l'air d'être
très informés pour avoir eu accès à un
dossier d'eau pertes et lâchait merter
france n'est pas avisé officiellement à
l'heure où sparrow effectivement david
koubbi 12 papier un écrit sur rtl vous
venez de la cité libération
regardez un l'un des titres 1
désinformation pourquoi rt front se
retrouve dans l'oeil de gendarme de
l'audiovisuel ou encore l'article du
parisien vendredi dernier chen rt
interdite en allemagne comment la très
populaire version française traite la
crise ukrainienne 1 au passage on a pu
être interrogé une partie seulement de
nos réponses ont été publiés par nos
confrères du parisien justement régis 1
on parle du traitement de l'actualité
internationale ça a été beaucoup évoqué
dans ses diverses article manifestement
ça a passionné les foules on a de la
chance d'intéresser autant vous êtes
arrivé vous en début d'année sur la
chaîne ancien directeur on le rappelle
de paris match vous avez couvert de
nombreux conflits
quand vous lisez ces accusations qui
vont s'en fait notamment sur le
traitement de la crise du trio craignent
and mais pas seulement qu'elle et vous
votre sentiment de journalistes
écoutez moi j'ai eu le plaisir de
rencontrer notamment on va prendre le
cas de la du traitement de la crise du
crédit n puisque les allées elle est
encore en cours et que c'est en parle
beaucoup et qu'on a beaucoup débattu sur
ce plateau à la fois moi je me suis
manifester en en skate mais également en
présentiel sur le plateau j'ai eu la
joie de rencontrer
comment des gens de croiser des gens
comme le général dominique train quand
par exemple qui était le le conseiller
militaire des manuels macron pendant la
campagne électorale qui est aussi été un
chef de la mission militaire de la
délégation française à l'onu aux
nations-unies à new york également et
avant-hier soir j'ai croisé franck
louvrier qui l'ancien comment conseiller
en communication de 2 comment nicolas
sarkozy où l'ambassadeur claude blanc
blanche maison qui a été ambassadeur en
russie donc des gens qui ont été qui ont
eu des commandes et rôle important
auprès justement du président la
république pour l'un d'entre eux et pour
les autres qui en comptait voilà et ces
gens sont venus discuter justement de
cette crise l'ukrainienne on a pu en
débattre les débats ont été le trouve
d'une grande qualité on a pu aussi
comment avoir la vie du photographe très
important jérôme sessini qui fait partie
de la prestigieuse agence de photos
magnum qui est titulaire de trois world
press donc quelqu'un qui a ouvert une
cité de conflit est particulièrement
l'ukraine et jérôme sessini était très
intéressant pourquoi parce que jérôme
sessini a précisément couvert l'ukraine
des deux côtés il a couvert le medan le
comment le le début de la révolte à
medan et ensuite il s'est rendu au
donbass donc il a couvert les deux camps
il n'a pu nous raconter finalement ce
que les ukrainiens qu'il avait rencontré
de part et d'autre penser la guerre il
ya passé un temps considérable donc
c'est je trouve en plus dans cette
dimension photographique il y avait une
dimension humaine très importante et qui
est un peu
édulcoré dans d'autres médias c'est
qu'on doit effectivement les routes
diplomatique les marathon diplomatique
on peut les appeler les histoires de
chef d'état mais finalement assez peu la
vie des gens qui sont là bas donc en
tout cas
et pardonnez-moi registre on va pas se
donner la parole effectivement à notre
ami sur ce plateau dans tous ces
articles il ya un nom on en parlait tout
à l'heure un qui revient régulièrement
maxime udine 1 cherche alors à l'irsem
l'institut de recherche stratégique de
l'école militaire
davy de ce lot comme vous êtes vous
américain historien des médias où vous
êtes justement intéressés à ces écrits
ce livre est semble-t-il pris comme une
référence jusqu'au département d'état
américain comme nous l'expliqué thomas
bonnet c'est quand même pas rien c'est
cécile crédible ce qui est écrit dans
cet ouvrage
enfin
je trouve ce livre de maxime au dîner
extrêmement problématique car il se
présente comme une étude académique qui
a alors qu'il s'agit en fait c'est un
récit populaire qui repose sur des
décennies de vue critique occidentale de
la russie
et cela repose également sur de
profondes cité culturelle sur les
changements dans les médias est à
l'environnement des médias
ce qui trouble d'ailleurs la plupart
d'entre nous
la
c'est beaucoup de sujets d'exemples
historiques
il a introduit très ce pôle de recherche
originel original il a amené très peu
d'entretien notamment avec présence en
bleu partez mais en règle générale il se
faut sur des recherches souvent
assez superficiel les recherches
d'autres personnes et en matière de
motions l'une est flagrant que c'est que
malgré toutes ses affirmations sur le
biais de arte sur la partialité de arte
ils ne présentent
pas dans la liste de conclure rigoureuse
il présente des échantillons
très léger des anecdotes qui servent à
illustrer son propos il a
illustré des critiques déjà très
familière par exemple la le traitement
par orthez 2 par pertes et de
l'impérialisme américain
il s'agit beaucoup plus d'une histoire
que d'une étude
et cela on est sans doute à des
personnes qui sont du même avis que ce
méchant mais ce n'est pas une vraie
ruche quand on le voit on a invité donc
maxime au dîner qui a réfuté notre
invitation c'est bien dommage il aurait
pu en débattre avec vous parce qu'on
tente spécialiste des médias elle je le
répète vous avez donc lu en détail ce
lycée pour ça que vous êtes là
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'ils l'apportent
parfois tout même des des preuves de ce
que de ce qu'il dit à partir du moment
où le département d'état l'utilisons tu
peux espérer légitimement qu'il y ait
des preuves dans cet ouvrage
il faut de celui qui lie à ces
évolutions importantes en matière de
preuve mais il ya également le fait que
l'épreuve qui présent ce
sont des références à d'autres travaux
universitaires
partiel ou parfois contradictoires
vis-à-vis des sources d'origine
je pense qu'il faut traiter ses preuves
de ce qu'il présente comme des preuves
avec beaucoup de prudence
et comme vous l'avez dit elle son rôle
en soutenant koné tiassé dommage
c'est que personnellement je trouve
frustrant tant que soliste et des médias
c'est que monsieur au dîner
tenir une discussion sur l'intégrité des
médias et pourtant son travail mon
intégrité donc il ya vraiment un grand
déficit donc je vous le disiez un david
d maxime au dîner repris par plusieurs
articles 1,12 article en une semaine
contre rt france david koubbi les les
campagnes médiatiques dans ce genre est
ce qu'on en a l'habitude chez arte
vous le dire est ce que vous vous en
avez l'habitude chez les non mais en
tant qu'avocat vous avez travaillé sur
ces dossiers
c'est la période qui veut ça on c'est
une habitude depuis cartes et existe non
non je veux être catégorique c'est
absolument la manière dont vous êtes
traité depuis que vous avez qui l'ont
ten c'est à dire que on a vu un certain
nombre de dogmes politiques se succéder
certains sénateurs certains responsables
de campagne certains proches de
d'emmanuel macro et manu macron lui-même
venons indiqué
avec une très grande nuance que rt
n'était pas un média mais un organe d'un
fluence étrangers financé par un pays
étranger la russie en l'occurrence et
qu'il était un outil de propagande
évidemment le manuel macro on n'a pas du
tout sale je viens de synthétiser ce qui
a été dit par l'ensemble des politiques
de l'environnement de là ma chronique
beau alors tout ça ça pourrait
fonctionner s'il n'y avait pas le
gendarme de l'audiovisuel le csa hier l
art comme aujourd'hui qui lorsqu'il est
saisi entre envoi de sanctions après
l'envoi d'une mise en demeure il est
vrai que votre chaîne parce que je crois
qu'il faut être transparent a reçu en
2018 une mise en demeure pour une
difficulté dont vous étiez à s'expliquer
devant le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel à l'époque qui était une
difficulté technique vous vous en mettre
expliqué et ça a été admis et ensuite
lorsqu'une procédure a été sur un autre
sujet
amener à maturité jusqu'à ce qu'une
notification sanction soit fait il si
une proposition de sanction je vous prie
de m'excuser cette procédure a été menée
à son terme et j'ai ici les attendus je
me permets de de lire de ligne et demi
parce que je crois que c'est important
article 1er il n'y a pas lieu de
prononcer de sanction à l'encontre de la
société capter france article 2 la
présente décision sera notifiée à la
société rt publié au journal officiel de
la république française pourquoi est-ce
que je vous lis ce deuxième article
faisant l'objet d'une publication au jo
de la république française parce que
lorsque l'on lit l'article de vos
confrères de libération ils font masse
d'un certain nombre de critiques que
vous connaissez bien et je ne suis pas
là pour les pour les rappeler ni pour
les compiler ce n'est pas mon travail
mais
lorsqu'il égrène les procédures ou rt a
été accroché par donnez moi du terme
parce qu'elle a été dans un viseur
quelconque lors l'occurrence en ce
moment on dirait que ce soit une
association
dont on attend encore entendu parler qui
sont l'avoir été créé à dessein pour
poursuit-on poursuivre rt devant mark
holmes et bien libération plus
exactement le journaliste de libération
home est totalement de mentionner cette
décision de février 2020 du 26 février
2000 voir les gens peuvent aller la voir
elle est publiée au jo et il se trouve
que comme par hasard c'est celle qui
vous est favorable ce qui est quand même
assez
curieux je me permet d'élargir si j'ai
juste
pris très rapidement on est en train ici
de discuter de droits fondamentaux c'est
à dire pour ceux qui nous regardent de
la liberté d'informer les journalistes
d'ayrté sont des journalistes qui sont
français qui sont des journalistes qui
ont officié sur d'autres chaînes pendent
autres supports peut-elle régis le
sommier qui intervient aujourd'hui avec
nous qui sont titulaires de carte de
presse et qui sont à longueur de
colonnes insulté
de manière très directe lorsqu'il dit
qu'il travaille au service d'un organe
de presse étranger ou d'un organe
influences étrangères syrte est un
organe de presse ils influencent
étrangers allant contre les ennemis de
la france eh bien je crois car tu es
peut être sanctionné mais sur des
éléments dont nous avons connaissance
dans la presse désolé de vous couper
mais on va nous couper sinon nous le
sifflet et le faisceau merci beaucoup à
vous merci à régis le sommier david
hauss lucuma merci beaucoup d'être venu
sur le plateau d arte france a c'est la
fin de cette émission se retrouvent
demain 20h non pas demain d'ailleurs
nous sommes jeudi lundi à 20h
l'information continue l'assuré arte
france
[Musique]
bienvenue dans un free connecte à 89 ans
paul biya cumule plus de 30